The Swiss parliament has elected a new government today!
Here are three things you should know about the Federal Council.
One: Switzerland's government will be led by a woman -
Viola Amherd.
She is only the sixth woman to hold this position
since the first woman president was elected in 1999.
The office of Swiss president rotates every year
among the seven cabinet ministers
and in 2024 it will be current defence minister Viola Amherd.
Two: the only newly elected councillor today is Social Democrat Beat Jans.
He took the place of his departying party member Alain Berset,
who resigned last July.
His wife may be American,
but Jans is very much focused on the European front.
Originally from Basel
he made his home canton the most European in Switzerland.
Now he believes EU-Swiss negotiations need to be brought to a swift conclusion.
Three: Swiss political stability has won once more.
All former members of the government have been re-elected.
However, it was not all dull and predictable.
The right-wing parties did not stick to the script
and settle for the two candidates nominated
by the Social Democrats.
Several rounds of voting were necessary to settle the issue.
That being said,
it still remained nothing more than a skirmish.
What do you think about these results?
Let us know in the comments.